I'm getting little are [ __ ] noms okay
hey guys I'm a t-shirt welcome to Abby's
kitchen with the holidays here I
partnered up with my friends at crave
gourmet jerky to bring you three healthy
holiday snack mixes that you're
definitely gonna want to have on hand
for those times when unexpected guests
just show up at your door and you don't
want them getting passed out drunk on
boxed wine with editing snacks you know
what I'm saying and while most snack
mixes are basically just cereal nuts in
candy coated in oil and sugar mine
offers a nice balance of fiber healthy
fats and protein from crave gourmet
jerky I am obsessed with this stuff I
featured it already in this video for my
summer healthy protein snacks but it's
great it's got eight grams of protein
per ounce has less sodium than most of
the brands out there and has no
artificial flavors or added
preservatives it is delicious all on its
own but it's a real treat and these
snack mixes so let's do this so the
first thing we want to do is make the
popcorn from scratch I add about a half
cup of popcorn kernels to a nonstick
skillet over medium heat with a touch of
oil then I let the kernels pop until I
stop hearing the popping noise and I
carefully open up the lid first is my
fiesta mix to season the popcorn I mixed
together coconut oil lime zest chili
powder and sea salt
I add that to the popcorn along with
some crave chili lime beef jerky some
toasted cashews toasted coconut and
dried mango next up is my cherry
chocolate and almond mix for this recipe
I mixed together some coconut oil lemon
zest cinnamon brown sugar and sea salt I
add that to the popcorn along with a
pack of crave black cherry barbecue pork
jerky dried cherries sliced toasted
almonds and mini dark chocolate chips
finally my teriyaki wasabi mix for this
batch of popcorn I seasoned it with
coconut oil coconut sugar wasabi powder
cayenne and a pinch of sea salt I then
add a pack of crave sweet teriyaki pork
jerky wasabi peas rice crackers and
peanuts
so thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed these recipes and video
if you did be sure to give it the thumbs
up subscribe to the channel and leave me
a comment below with some of your
favorite snacks that you keep on hand
for the holidays help see you next time
on Abby's kitchen
[Music]
you
[Music]